alors que les campagnes de vaccination
s'accélère enfin un doute a soudainement
surgi cette semaine à propos du vaccin
contre la coved 19 de la compagnie
astrazeneca le 8 mars l'autriche par le
bas un lot de vaccins est alors suspendu
après le décès d'une infirmière de 49
ans morte de caillots de sang
deux semaines auparavant elle avait reçu
une dose de vaccin
ensuite d'autres décès sont aussi
recensés
ailleurs en europe rapidement la peur
augmente et l'effet domino se produit
tour à tour une quinzaine de pays
suspende l'administration du vaccin
d'astrazeneca
mais à ce jour il n'existe aucun lien de
causalité entre les effets secondaires
recensés et le vaccin en question
une chose est certaine cet épisode
s'ajoute à la confusion déjà alimenté
par la désinformation basé sur des
vaccins
bon il fallait je pense attendre un
moment donné à ce genre d'événement de
couverture médiatique de réactions de
méfiance je propose qu'on y aille
morceau par morceau
mary kerr d'abord les cas de thrombose
le qui sont au centre de la sphère
astrazeneca
ils sont bel et bien réels mais comme
l'on statue lots à metz et l'agencé
européenne des médicaments doit pas
s'inquiéter outre mesure
non parce que les risques de thrombose
en général donc la formation de caillots
dans les vaisseaux sanguins
ils sont pas plus élevé chez ceux qui
reçoivent le vaccin d'astrazeneca ça
l'agencé européenne des médicaments leur
conclu après avoir analysé
rigoureusement les données et confie
aussi que les bénéfices dépassent de
beaucoup les risques la vaccination
maintenant les petites préoccupations
qui subsistent elles sont liées à un
type très très très précis de thrombose
très rare aussi la thrombose veineuse
cérébral il ya eu d'échos chez des
personnes quand même assez jeunes entre
20 et 55 ans
l' agence de santé publique de
l'allemagne un des pays qui a suspendu
la vaccination au rendu ces données
publiques et on parle de sept personnes
sur 1,6 million de personnes qui ont
reçu le vaccin
c'est très peu mais c'est quand même un
peu plus que ce à quoi on s'attend dans
la population générale
normalement on parle d'une personne sur
1,6 million qui développent ce type de
thrombose l'a donc avec le vaccin
si le lien démontré ce serait cette fois
plus mais il faut vraiment relativiser
ce risque-là bon si jamais on confirme
que les cèpes thrombose sont bien liés
au vaccin l'eau ce qui est loin d'être
une certitude ça voudrait dire que le
risque est de 0,0001 44 % le risque
habituels lui un sur 1,6 million et
20.000 0 6%
donc notre cette fois plus de risques ce
que ça veut dire concrètement c'est que
le risque
il augmente de 0 0 0 0 38%
ça passe mieux comme ça c'est normal de
se poser des questions et c'est ce que
ces pays la faune
mais il faut pas oublier que par exemple
en grande-bretagne où on a un système de
surveillance semblables on administre et
plus de 11 millions de doses du vaccin
et on n'a pas du tout des noté
d'augmentation du risque même en fait
c'est l'inversé d'un point de vue
purement statistique et recevoir la
veille le vaccin ça ferait diminuer les
risques
ici aussi du côté de santé canada mais
on n'a vraiment pas dénoté
d'augmentation maintenant c'est certain
qu'on peut comprendre la personne dans
la vingtaine qui se diraient qui elle a
vraiment pas beaucoup de risques d'avoir
des complications si jamais elle attrape
là que vivent encore moins de risque
d'en mourir et qui veut pas prendre le
risque le même infime de faire une
thrombose veineuse cérébrale mais il
faut peut-être comparer ça à un autre
risque peu élevé
disons-le ajustements le risque de
mourir de l'aco vide si cette personne
ne la trappe
donc on attend qu'on parle d'une
personne de 25 ans ce risque là et de
0,01 pour ça donc c'est quand même
beaucoup plus que notre 0,00 0 44%
on parle donc d'un risque 23 fois plus
élevé l'américaine a bien pris le temps
de mettre tous en contexte
jeff c'est pas toujours le cas dans tous
les éléments d'information qui ont
concerné cette affaire-là médiatiquement
toi
si on regarde sur le plan large qu'est
ce que tu en penses mais c'est toujours
difficile pour les médias généralistes
de couvrir des enjeux scientifiques
surtout dans un cas comme ci ou les
conclusions scientifiques le somport
finale les médias doivent rapporter les
faits il ya eu des thromboses chez des
personnes qui ont eu le bac gris vaccin
c'est un fait il ya eu certains pays qui
ont décidé de mettre sur pause leurs
programmes de vaccination en retrait à
donnée corps
c'est un fait on doit apporter on ne
peut pas cacher des informations
publiques mais elle a quand même l'effet
où la culture la couverture demeurera
membre de cet événement là ont un peu un
effet d'amplification donc quelqu'un par
exemple qui voit la recherche
l'information s'avère très haut les
coeurs sentir dans google actualités
voit juste voir les gros titres
et souvent c'est très difficile de faire
transparaître ses nuances là dans les
grands titres donc faut lire l'article
en question
mais quand on fait je regardais les
résultats de recherche mais on ne juge
cet article après article qui dit que le
vaccin était bloqué dans certains pays
parce que des risques de thrombose donc
c'est toujours un exercice qui est très
difficile surtout pour des sujets
scientifiques de faire transparaître
toutes les nuances dans la couverture
médiatique - la couverture médiatique en
général comme tu le dis si on regarde ça
d'un peu plus près sur le web qu'est ce
que tu en penses
c'est là que ça se complique un peu
parce que souvent les maisons mon frère
en une couverture très nuancée du vaccin
mais les articles apparaissent sur les
réseaux sociaux déduits de leur contexte
donc un exemple parfait c'est cet
article du journal de montréal qui parle
d'un code thrombose potentiellement liés
au vaccin ici au canada
il n'y a pas de problème avec l'article
cite un article basé sur les faits c'est
pas de la faute du genre à montréal mais
cet article à voyage seul sur les
réseaux sociaux
mais dans son contexte original dalle
journal quand le journal de jeudi matin
bin cet article est accompagné d'un
immense du dossier qui disait écoutait
pas de panique avec les vaccins donnés
les statistiques dont nous parlait
marie-pierre plus tôt donc pour la
personne qui dit le journal c'est quand
même clair le contexte oui il ya ce
qu'aulas mais faut quand même tempéré
avec les statistiques de ce qu'on
connaît sur toutes ces situations là
mais sur les réseaux sociaux dans
twitter dans facebook
c'est l'article seul sur le code
thrombose qui circulent ça peut donner
une fausse impression
pas de la faute du média sur la foi de
journaliste mais s'ils sont un peu les
faits justement des réseaux sociaux des
contextes à tout le monde en est
conscient du sopi nicolas bien sûr la
nouvelle elle a rapidement été récupérés
par le mouvement antivaccin c'est de
l'or en barre pour le mouvement
antivaccin ça leur donne des munitions
et certains en sortent par exemple que
des activistes anti vaccins vont 30
d'assaut les sections commentaires
d'articles de médias sur les réseaux
sociaux pour dire vous voyez c'est la
preuve les vaccins c'est dangereux ça
fait aussi en sorte que ces gens là sont
pas obligés de partager des articles de
source
toews pour remettre en question
l'efficacité des vaccins ils ont
simplement trouvé un article avec un
titre un peu alarmiste un titre un peu
sensationnalisme partager ça ça renforce
leur point de vue ça renforce leur
croyance ils peuvent semer le doute par
la suite auprès de leurs abonnés auprès
de leurs connaissances leurs familles
gras mais reste que certaines personnes
vont encore plus loin on voit de la
désinformation c'est à dire des
tentatives délibérées d'émettre des
informations fausses ou trompeuses et
des théories du complot qui surgissent
aussi
ouais les publications convoi qui disent
tout simplement que le vaccin
astrazeneca provoque des thromboses donc
on simplifie énormément la chose on
enlève toute nuance ça vient soutenir
n'importe quel thèses anti vaccins pour
un peu prendre un nouvel n'a hélas pu
mener à notre sauce finalement mr et oh
décrypteurs on s'est attardé au fil des
mois plusieurs de ces théories
trompeuses faux ce pour le bien tout le
monde méfions nous de ce réflexe naturel
de partager sans hésiter sur les réseaux
sociaux des publications qui nous
conforte dans nos peurs dans nos
craintes et dans le dos tu écrivais non
et on essaiera de vous aider tout ce qui
se dit et s'écrit sur les vaccins a le
potentiel d'influencé l'adhésion de la
population aux campagnes de vaccination
contre la coved 19 mai selon les
derniers coups de sonde
l'adhésion au vaccin demeure
relativement élevé dans bien des pays
à la question êtes vous prêt à recevoir
un vaccin pour voyants par pays
les proportions de ceux qui ont répondu
oui parmi les personnes sondées en
février dernier 65% des américains
76 % des suédois 89 % des britanniques
et 59% des français puis au québec
74 % des personnes sondées se disent
prêtes à se faire vacciner contre la
coved 19 selon une étude récente de
l'université de sherbrooke dans certains
contextes l'adhésion vaccinale peut être
volatile qu'en est-il en temps de
pandémie quand la désinformation circule
abondamment f dubé bonjour et bienvenue
décrypteurs mangeant vous êtes
anthropologue médical affilié à
l'institut national de santé publique du
québec
j'aimerais vous entendre sur le
tourbillon médiatique qui étaient
générés par la sphère astrazeneca des
centaines de québec ont refusé ce vaccin
là au cours des derniers jours va
prendre un vaccin qui me reste de grande
valeur non merci beaucoup
quand vous évaluer l'effet du traitement
médiatique dans tout ça c'est certain
que la médiatisation des faits
secondaires a toujours des conséquences
puis on s'est même si ses effets
secondaires leçon de saveur pour causé
par un vaccin lui démenti de la santé
publique sont toujours moins porteur que
les premières accusations sur
l'excellent duo dangereux et sécuritaire
ça fait une dizaine d'années que je
travaille dans le champ de
l'acceptabilité des vaccins que j'ai
jamais vu autant d'intérêt et de
couverture médiatique sur des vaccins
qu'en ce moment
évidemment tous les jeunes à beaucoup de
confusion dans le public
jusqu'à quel point ça peut avoir une
influence généralement sur des personnes
qu'on ne peut pas qualifier de
conspirationnisme et qui sont dans plus
de limitations vaccinale on sait qu'une
des premières raisons pour les quais
pour laquelle tant hésitation avec smith
et des préoccupations par rapport à la
sécurité d'un vaccin donc évidemment ces
associations le temporel où ce risque
accru de faits secondaires l'eau mais
peut générer plusieurs craintes ou
d'août puis si ces craintes le sont pas
bien répondu par les professionnels à
nantes et metz à peu se cristalliser un
refus retarde avec six nations mais
comment on devrait s'y prendre pour
rétablir la confiance de la population
selon vous la transparence des les
bonnes stratégies communication je pense
que c'est ce qu'on a fait au québec
les experts sont sorties dans les médias
pour expliquer la situation pour
rassurer le public ce qu'on a vu dans le
passé c'est que la posture de suspendre
un vaccin en s'appuyant sur le principe
de précaution la le signal est pas super
solide
on sait que ça allait des impacts le
majeur puis à long terme sur
l'acceptabilité des vaccins et puis les
experts qui se prononce nous qui faisons
comme journaliste un travail pour
rétablir les faits est ce que ça peut
être avant n'est pas quelconque pour
ceux qui croient dur comme fer qu'ils
ont et danger dans ses batteries on
évalue l'information à la lumière de nos
valeurs puis nos attitudes existants
donc les gens qui avaient déjà eu
certaines craintes ou certaine
appréhension s'appelait confirmés dans
leurs hésitations maintenance convient
c'est pas juste une pandémie c'est aussi
une info des vies dans toute cette
information là que contradictoires
confuse peut générer des doutes
légitimes chez les gens qui se passait
là le king un enjeu certain que pension
terminaux de ces politiciens qui est se
font publiquement vacciner est-ce que ça
c'est genre de stratégie de
communication qui peut avoir un effet
positif
je dirais que oui quand on parle de la
sécurité l'efficacité d'un vaccin salle
un certain impact chez les gens mais
quand on dit j'ai vacciner mes enfants
où je vais recommander à ma mère de
recevoir le pack est encore plus vive
je pense à laisser un message positif
est-ce que ça va convaincre les
personnes récalcitrantes je pense pas
malheureusement f du met merci beaucoup
pour cet entretien
merci